after six seasons years of rich
historical drama and a great deal of
raiding success
what exactly made history decide to ax
its flagship
show these are the real reasons why
vikings is finally coming to an end
growing up on his parents farm in
australia travis fimmel was a million
miles away from the bright lights of
hollywood
but a chance encounter with a modeling
scout changed the course of his life
forever
after a stint working in london he
decided to try his luck stateside and
according to the sydney morning herald
was offered a contract instantly after
quote swaggering barefoot into la models
he quickly became the face of calvin
klein but while he made money posing in
his underwear
he was also fine-tuning his acting
skills fimmel had a number of roles in
australia prior to vikings but it was
playing the show's enigmatic lead that
brought him
international recognition his intense
and often sympathetic portrayal
of farmer turned viking leader ragnar
lothbrok was the true heart of the show
so when the character was killed off in
season four vikings entered
uncharted territory according to forbes
writer eric kane
it was a gamble that ultimately didn't
pay off
after the show's cancellation he wrote
thank goodness the show has been lost at
sea for a long time now
and probably should have wrapped with
the death of ragnar and departure of
lead travis fimmel
when ragnar met his end in season 4
viewers were supposed to get on board
with the idea of his sons heading to
england to avenge his death
we were introduced to his firstborn son
bjorn way back in the first season
but we didn't really get to know the
rest of ragnar's brood until after the
season 4 time jump
vikings creator michael hurst told
variety it was very important to bring
on ragnar's sons i've invested a lot of
time hope and expectation in these suns
it's very important that the audience
invest in these new characters
unfortunately for hearst this never
really happened
despite his best efforts audiences just
didn't seem as interested in watching
the antics of ragnar's offspring
even when they were hell-bent on
avenging the man himself
after news of the show's end broke
forbes reported
ragnar's story was over a long time ago
and none of the stories that have come
since have resonated as much with
viewers tv equals placed the blame
directly at the feet of ragnar's sons
they wrote
the death of ragnar lothbrok has left a
void that his sons have not yet been
able to fill
most of ragnar's sons are kind of boring
history ordered a sixth season of
vikings before season five had even
begun
at the time nobody knew that the sixth
season would be the last
but the decision to cancel the show
seems to have been influenced
at least in part by a decline in
viewership
following the season 5 premiere carter
matt tried to soften the blow by
suggesting that it's hard for any cable
series to amass large numbers these days
but the facts are still hard to ignore
the outlet wrote
the bad news is that these radians are
down fairly substantially from the 0.8
rating that the show generated for its
season 4 premiere back in february 2016.
it's also down about 9 in total viewers
versus the average season 4 rating the
vikings premiere is down about 13
in the demo and 4 in the viewers this
wasn't a new trend
either the previous season also saw a
significant drop
according to tv series finale season 4
of vikings was down by a whopping 28
in the demo and 44 in viewers
history renewed anyway but the network
must have recognized that the show was
approaching its end
one surefire way of getting waning
viewers to stick with the show is to
announce
that the next season will be the last
and it seems the network wanted to wrap
vikings up before it saw a mass
exodus gustav skarsgard's floki has been
a fan favorite since day one but the
character underwent wholesale changes
in season 5. he sails with ragnar's sons
as part of the great heathen army
but once they avenge him floki becomes
little more than a spare part
i feel trapped in all this
happiness i feel trapped he then takes
to the seas alone
and puts himself at the mercy of the
gods who lead him to what he believes to
be asgard but we know today is iceland
floki decides to bring a handful of
settlers to this new wild land
hoping to build a community free of the
violence that had become an
everyday part of viking life despite
floki's attempts at keeping the peace
petty arguments turn into blood feuds
and the settlement struggles
it ought to have run across a few
episodes at best but the iceland plot
was still ongoing at the end of season
five
testing the patience of many viewers one
ticked off redditer wrote
i can't believe i gave hearst the
benefit of the doubt with this storyline
the drama between avond and floki has
been forced from the start
and they've made absolutely no effort to
get us to care about any of the new
characters
floki's voyage to iceland may have been
inspired by true events but sadly it
made for some pretty boring television
when travis fimmel departed vikings
katherine winik became the new anchor of
the show
ragnar's first wife lagertha has always
been loved by fans
so this seemed a smart move but while
winik made a name for herself playing
lagertha like fimmel it was only a
matter of time before she
too moved on to bigger things vikings
may have sailed a little off course in
season 5 but winik remains in demand
the dark tower was a letdown for her and
polar didn't exactly go to plan
but winik is set to return to tv with a
brand new netflix show in 2019
woo assassins a martial arts crime
series set in san francisco's chinatown
winix in show son alexander ludwig is
also a hot property thanks to his
portrayal of bjorn ironside
ludwig had previously appeared in the
hunger games franchise but
vikings catapulted him to new levels of
fame he told channel 24
i'd never experienced anything like that
it's amazing how much this show has
really affected people in all walks of
life globally
it's not a stretch to imagine that
ludwig must be in as much demand as
winik and fimmel
when the first episode of the last
kingdom aired in 2015
some had already dismissed it as a
vikings knockoff
by the time the first season was done
however many mines had been changed
in its review for the show the av club
wrote bbc america's sprawling arresting
eight-part historical miniseries the
last kingdom
proves that there's room enough on
television for more than one viking
invasion the show
which is based on the saxon stories
novels by bernard cornwell
was praised by critics across the board
creating an instant rivalry with vikings
of course vikings and the last kingdom
aren't the only two shows set during
that tumultuous period in european
history
when eric kane expressed relief over
vikings ending in his forbes piece
he pointed out that the market was
becoming highly saturated
kane wrote we have the last kingdom
airing still on netflix after all
oh and there's also the wonderful
norsemen biking shows are becoming like
zombie shows
norsemen is a comedy show so it wasn't
ever really a direct threat to vikings
but its success further proves that
history isn't the only network capable
of creating a compelling show
about the viking way of life the viking
trend has also hit the big screen with
northmen a viking saga arriving hot on
the heels of vikings in 2014
and norse culture remains prevalent in
hollywood today thanks to the how to
train your dragon franchise
viewers have lots of different places to
go should they want a viking fix
and vikings itself has suffered for that
fact
despite everything many vikings fans
still believe that the show is being
sent to valhalla far
too soon disgruntled viewers took to
twitter to vent when the news broke
comedian kathleen madigan among them
she tweeted vikings is being canceled
after season six
i'll just go ahead and prepare my own
viking funeral in solidarity
sad news and while some fans might point
out that the show has already covered
everything historians know about ragnar
and his sons
that doesn't necessarily mean vikings
has to end
hearst others show the tudors was
notorious for being historically
inaccurate
but even leading historians admitted
that the things hurst added worked well
for tv
dr tracy borman told the telegraph yes
the scriptwriters may have taken
liberties with the facts
but they have also succeeded in
recreating the drama and atmosphere of
henry viii's court
viking star alexander ludwig has praised
hearst's willingness to take a creative
liberty with the show
which he could well have continued to do
for many more seasons
the decline in ratings was undoubtedly
on the mind of history executives when
they agreed to bring vikings to
an end but michael hearst didn't mention
any of that when he sat down with
variety in january 2019.
officially the interview was about the
season 5 finale but the show's
cancellation inevitably came up
pressed for details first claimed that
six seasons was actually enough time for
him to tell the story he wanted to tell
from the very beginning
he said what i was trying to do was
write the saga of ragnar lothbrok and
his sons
after six seasons and 89 episodes that's
what i felt
finally i'd done i had no reason to want
to continue it beyond that
don't waste your time looking back
you're not going that way
hurst was quick to remind variety
readers that the funeral pyre hadn't
been lit
just yet in an effort to lift spirits
among the wounded fans
the showrunner started hyping up the
sixth and final season
he told the publication we visit three
new worlds in those episodes we go
through great tragedies and great
heroism
and if you have tears to weep be
prepared to weep them as you watch
season
6. i'm very proud of the show i did what
i wanted to do
that's the truth losing vikings is a
huge blow for the show's many dedicated
fans but it was softened by news that a
spin-off series is in the cards
when variety asked hurst what he had
planned for this new show
the writer and producer said that he
considers it a continuation series
we were defeated we lived to fight
another day hurst went on to explain
that he had developed an attachment to
the characters he brought to life in
vikings
which is why he wanted to be involved in
any new show set in that world
hurst said i have to say that they're
not characters to me i write so much
about them i've lived with them for
seven years
they're real people to me so i care and
have been caring about them for a long
time
i want to guide them through whatever
storylines they have
so does this mean we'll see more of our
favorite viking characters pop up in
this continuation series
and what does continuation series even
mean first explain
continuation means that if we make it it
will be connected to my saga
it may not involve necessarily the same
characters i can't go into more details
than that but for the fans of the show
it will be a continued enjoyment to the
vikings experience
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you